[Applause]
that's what drove me crazy i think we
talked about on patreon about about the
chloe thing
yeah like where chloe has this picture
of her come out right
and it's not perfectly photoshopped like
the rest of her pictures and then she
goes it's just
she tries to get white for the internet
and she's like it's just so hard for me
to keep up with the
uh the societal expectations of a
woman's body type
and it's like you [ __ ] that's the
expectation [ __ ]
yeah you [ __ ] wretched [ __ ] i love
it
you and your family yes have been making
women fee all of our wives and
girlfriends feel insecure
every single day for photoshopping your
images
carving up your [ __ ] skeletons
shooting [ __ ] in your body
to create unrealistic standards for
women right
you've been doing for the entire waking
every woman on the planet that can't
afford that [ __ ]
or it wasn't born even close to the way
that you fraudulently look
making them feel like [ __ ] yep and made
billions of dollars in the process right
making women feel like [ __ ]
yep right and then you're gonna act
like the victim of your own creation mr
frankenstein
if you get killed by the robot that's on
you homie that's on you you made a
[ __ ] robot yeah yeah robots go to
robots sometimes why are you saying bolt
complaining about the world record
he's like who made it so fast how dare
they who did that dare they make a
record
it was unbelievable bro i i couldn't i
was infuriated by it
yeah and i'm not trying to be like
protective of women or something about
over this i'm just
i hate people who have blood money
and play victim or who have blood money
and play virtuous
yeah you really hate that i [ __ ] hate
if you
make your money with blood yep now
they're not killing people
but they are not making people feel good
no okay so you made your money
for sure exactly harmful or helpful not
even a question harmful
blood money right i don't cry about how
you're bleeding
yeah you chose that sport yeah you know
what i'm saying you chose to play
quarterbacks sometimes you get concussed
yeah that's what you chose if you want
to make the blood money and then not be
virtuous or cry at all i'm hey bro do
you get yours
a lot of people made blood money in this
country the kennedys got some blood
money
every rich [ __ ] got some blood
money yeah uh mark
reading this documentary right now or
reading this book right now about
rockefeller
[ __ ] got blood yeah people got
blood and that's okay
but if you play virtuous that drives me
crazy too yeah
you're gonna have blood money and then
tell me how to live yeah [ __ ]
you got blood on your hands
yeah generally speaking choose one or
the other i'm gonna be virtuous
generally
or i'm gonna get my blood money
generally yeah man this this playing a
victim [ __ ] is
i don't know just don't say nothing
right it's so easy you're not saying
that but i gotta feel bad for you and we
respect the people who don't say nothing
and oh no
i think that's part of why we love the
joker bro this guy's just a [ __ ]
he just loves mayhem and that's what it
is and there's never any like because
the ecosystem needed to be
evened out yeah i love this i love that
she experienced this because now you
know what
every girl experiences when they post
their bikini on instagram
and they're scrolling through their [ __ ]
and then they see one of you or your
sisters
yeah every single one go oh [ __ ] my body
doesn't look like that yeah
my face doesn't look all these girls
right now gotta put a filter on their
face just to post a picture on their
story
you know how tragic that [ __ ] is they
look at their own face
and they go this isn't good enough for
the world to see
so i'm gonna put [ __ ] deer ears on it
yeah and then i can post it that [ __ ] is
tragic bro
yeah that's crazy it's gross it's more
sad when it's not even the animation
when it's just the subtle change
make your nose a little smaller oh
that's face tuned [ __ ] you can make your
face look like however you want it's
crazy
yeah it's crazy yeah it's just yeah
so if you are responsible for this
partly i'm not going to put everything
on them but they are partners
leaders of it they're definitely leaders
and they make billions of dollars doing
this [ __ ]
you don't get to cry when it comes back
on you hell no you shut the [ __ ] up
and you take it yeah simple as that yeah
or get out the game
i got a little respect for the courtney
because she did the lease surgery but
also without the game
she's just like look i don't want to be
part of it right now she's i'm miserable
and she did the least [ __ ] so like all
right fair enough
i never get riled up with the
kardashians because their currency is
attention
so it's like that's hey let me defeat
the standard and [ __ ]
cry about it it's like i'm getting
attention from both sides so she's not
even really crying she's just like i
need to get some attention yeah no i'm
she was trending topic for a picture
leaking i still don't even believe the
picture leaked
i think create the problem and then cry
about the problem they're currency
they are literally bond villains yeah
they've mastered it though but do you
remember that bond movie where like
they created the tragedy and then wrote
about it in the news
like the guy was this like media mogul
and he's like we'll just create the
terror attack and then we'll be the
first ones to report on it yeah
like that's what they're doing they're
terrorizing the internet and then
reacting to the terror yeah that's fine
so just throw some [ __ ] gas on it
they're the best
no i don't think they they are beasts
yeah i don't think she's doing that i
think she's genuinely affected but
respect if that's what they're doing i
just don't think it is and either way us
giving it attention
they just make more money every time we
talk about them they make money now i'll
be honest with you right now if she came
out and she was like
i realize how hypocritical i am i
[ __ ] i it was embarrassing for me to
even say that
that's my bad i would i would take back
everything i just said mm-hmm
and and she was like i realize how like
us photoshopping [ __ ]
you know makes other people feel
uncomfortable makes women have
unrealistic standards so i can't really
be out here
complaining when a picture of me ends up
on the internet god forbid
yeah you know like you won't i would i
would go okay
you're good i'm with it yeah